you've got to follow that dream wherever
that dream may lead Elvis Presley once
crooned for many impersonators of the
king of rock and roll that dream leads
to the small Australian town of parks
for a few days every year people of all
ages from all around the world come here
Parks Elvis Festival is Australia's
Graceland
after two years of doing nothing and you
know us entertainers being at home it's
great to be back out again and the parks
is buzzing it's great for the economy
for parks and it's just great to see
everything back up and running again
foreign
this is the 30th edition of the event
which is returned after two years of
pandemic disruptions 25
000 visitors are in town providing the
local economy with the Boost of around
15 million dollars
to have everything back in full swing
after three years of drought two years
of covert and to have it back in full
swing is so important for the emotional
benefits to the community not only to
help it recover from a difficult few
years but also to prepare for what lies
ahead consumer confidence is falling in
Australia as interest rates rise so 2023
is expected to be tough It's been a
challenge for a lot of smaller
communities and businesses you know
we've seen plenty of businesses close
down and you know Fall by the wayside
you know during those trying times
[Applause]
for now those worries have been set
aside as thousands Channel The King
it is the atmosphere that people you
every Pub Club shop owner they dress up
they theme their stores everyone gets in
the spirit of the festival Elvis Presley
also sang about satisfying his soul by
having a party and that's exactly what
this Festival is all about Wayne Haye Al
Jazeera